[музика]
ну Вважайте що ми звідси почали
шукати Ну віку звідти
вони однакові трошки вище були
і ми їх звідси гнали Ну це вже наша
бригада тут працювала десятка да
Ну і ми зараз зупинилися бо в нас зараз
в суді девардент ми зараз стоїмо між
берестовий спірне то есть то що
показують там болото оце про нас так би
ви болото мішаємся як має бути але
болото в перемішку з гіпсом от побачите
зараз хлопці які [ __ ] скільки буде
правду Нічого не відбувається
гіпс це страшна справа
Ну звичайно тяжко ну по-перше погода
очевидно що
обстріли постійні не зпідбірні
прильоти Ну то есть я навіть десь
нарахував що будучи на позиції одні з
наших біля берега
десь приблизно за 7 годин ми нарахували
то що рахували 200 прильотів По посадці
бо наша посадка там в межах скільки там
плюс-мінус там 3 км от 200 прильотів
Ну звичайно не все в посадку перед
посадкою по посадці за посадкою трохи
ядра обстріли там артилерія
авіація Танчики працювали Все як має
бути Васильки шлях би їх трафив просто
жесть
Вони знають що 10 військовослужбова
бригада і вони ж переконані щоби тут всі
бандерівці знаєш
кровопивці а що не бендерівці
нас багато хлопців зі сходу служить
навіть льон мобілізували з святих
гірські хлопці прийшли до нас питання в
іншого Питання в тому що вони переконані
що ми ледь не елітна частина чи бригада
української збройних сил каже 10
Сошників вони по селах стріляють
ракетами тільки валять по тих
що як тотальне таке на нас полювання але
нічого ми його все буде добре
Україна понад усе тут
Коли мій брат стрибунець сказав Путін
[ __ ] моя мама знаєш що зробили перше що
подзвонила до мене каже синку шоу Мам ти
чув що Олег Що зробимо
Вся Україна чує він з родини вчителів
А тепер Всі матюкаються безперестати